ce weekend je me suis amusé
de savoir ce qu'elle est voté les
chroniqueurs et franchement je pense que
je suis pas mal
je vous dise
quoi qui t'a vexé
Castaldi Macron non mais ne dis pas
Castaldi Macron ça c'est sûr
Guillaume Genton
arrête
[Rires]
je pense Macron
Gilles Verdez Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous
voulez je vous dise ou pas non bah oui
non
pas vrai non non ça m'étonne que vos non
je pense je pensais que vous pourriez
trouver genre la salle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
franchement moi je ne te force pas moi
je le dis sans problème
[Applaudissements]
Parti communiste
oui voilà merci Daniel Moreau
non je peux pas dire
[Rires]
la France
je vais vous mettre dans des situations
compliquées alors et vous alors moi
Macron
j'ai vu qu'il y a eu des votes pour
Karim Benzema pour les personnalité ce
que vous savez s'il y a des gens qui ont
mis sur leur bulletin Cyril Hanouna
alors ça y est vous faites partie des
sueurs maintenant
[Applaudissements]
pour pernico
et ses parents ils vont ils vont lui
léguer au moins 24 millions
j'adore et elle me dit je sais pas si
Cyril il faut que tu votes Mélenchon et
tes parents de toute façon ils vont pas
te léguer 12 millions d'euros je dis oui
c'est vrai donc elle m'a dit bah voilà
elle est incroyable
c'est toi
[Rires]
vous pouvez enlever l'Alerte Enlèvement
on a trouvé la personne qui a voté
Valérie Pécresse c'est bon déjà ça
regardez c'est bien parce que vous allez
vous appeler pour moi
voilà
le mec il a changé de voiture je pense
Macron
non non pas pétresse
c'est même pas qui c'est
moi j'en connais aucun merci en tout cas
non mais en tout cas c'est marrant de le
dire mais vous n'êtes pas obligé Daniel
la beauté Fillon
[Rires]
je suis arrivé j'adore quand je suis
invité quand même une darka on avait
vraiment l'impression que c'est vraiment
le genre le gars de tu sais genre qui
vient voter genre genre ah Monsieur
Nouna
venez la souper monsieur
vous allez vous voulez voter maintenant
oui bah oui parce que sinon j'ai un truc
voilà merci et donc votre électronique
je m'en fous moi vous savez moi où les
papiers électroniques et donc voilà donc
la meuf elle dit comment faire et tout
c'est électronique c'est très rapide
c'est très rapide c'est très rapide
aussi je pense qu'il y a plein de gens
qui se trompent parce que chat est à des
trucs tu vois comme ça et en fait tu
vois tu sais pas trop je suis sûr qu'il
y a des gens qui sont trompés vous êtes
contre
vous pensez que ça s'affiche derrière
ça peut être piraté les gens n'ont pas
tous l'habitude à l'électronique on a
des papiers on peut servir de partout je
pense pas qu'ils aient su pour qui j'ai
voté il peut y avoir juste en partant il
y a un mec du bord qui m'a dit un petit
Poutou